so multiplication and division of
inequalities you must be really careful
with okay you have to think it through
in some ways the most important thing
the biggest tip I can give you is make
sure your inequalities are always facing
in the same direction that will save you
from a lot of number one confusion right
and number two just getting results from
Google it looks old okay but but having
everything copy of changing things you
can do with the inequalities are the
same Russian you cannot do when there
are different dresses okay so trying to
make them as similar to equality
equations how do I start to work with
this having these are the quality the
really important part of them is the
relationship between a and B and the
relationship between C and D okay the
fact that it's got these zeros on the
end what does that tell you in addition
just tells you that everything is
positive okay so in some ways what I'm
really is this and this okay now I'm
gonna somehow translate those into this
okay so the very first thing I'm gonna
do is if I just take those two let's
name him charlie
let's call this one just that these two
together okay and call this to just
those two together I'm gonna multiply
them okay and here's what I'm gonna
write down and let's think about it
before we move any further okay before
we just take it as intrusive if I say
one multiplier to okay being that let
you two qualities are facing the same
direction I'm going to say let's just
pause and make sure this actually works
okay who didn't even think of some
numbers for yourself that you can put
into it that would satisfy the
inequality right is this statement true
a and C are my bigger numbers okay out
of a and C I don't know how they relate
to each other okay but each of them is
kind of like I'm a big part with where's
being dear small so if you multiply two
numbers that are both bigger and
now that you know this the products are
gonna retain this same inequality okay
does that make sense so this is actually
this was all go from here here to here
is a property that you will have to use
in the future okay so alright now that
we've got that how am I going to get
from something like this which relates
all four of the numbers together that's
why it's useful to me because this
inequality does as well how am I gonna
get from here to here these are products
and these are ratios well they have to
divide by something but my question is
what shall i divide by look at it
carefully I'm gonna recommend by the way
in these um yeah good these early steps
these early days what are safe right
write down what every step like that you
go through is to transfer one line to
another okay with equations you can kind
of play fast and loose with them but
when you're doing inequalities right for
instance when you divide through by CD
you have to know what probably C and D
obey to know what happens is in equality
rejection of faces okay okay so if I
divide through by CD let's just let me
get this okay now the inequalities
facing in the same direction now again
not because I have to but because it's
useful to be I'm going to look down that
this is true as CD is greater than 0
okay I know C is better than 0 because C
and D both individually I greater than 0
okay so therefore their product also
must be positive okay now going to do
that I can cancel the C's cancel the DS
okay so over D be greater than B over C
okay so this is good it fits in with
what I'm trying to prove just watch out
inequalities are backwards that's why
they the other way around
okay but I'm missing obviously this
thing in the middle okay so this is true
but not sufficient okay so how can I
some wedge this guy in the middle what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna come back to
this line okay this lines really
critical so I'm gonna so if I have a
think about three great if I want to get
these and sort of going towards
something like this I've got to get this
weed over obviously just simple
multiplying and dividing will not get me
there okay
cuz as much more Adam I need to get you
better had a plus sign in there so I
need to add something to both sides and
then do my divining and then I can get
my ratios the question is what shall I
add now think about this carefully what
you may like to do is get a pencil or a
different color do this off on the side
okay
this is usually a big no-no in terms of
actually proving like setting out your
proof but it's still useful in terms of
became we work out what steps should I
do so I'm just gonna write it over here
and I'm just gonna work with it for a
second okay now the reason why you can't
do this in the main body of your proof
okay what you actually submit is your
haircut is because in order to work with
this I'm assuming it's true right so as
soon as you've done that it's all about
okay any any conclusion you draw from
here will not be useful for an actual
proof because you've assumed that it
works you can't improve by contradiction
I think in this case it's a bit overkill
because it's actually algebraically it's
quite straightforward to get through
okay but what I'm gonna do is go from
here and see if I can notice some
insights about how this what endpoint
I'm trying to get to to see how I should
muck around with the equations okay so
like I said this is a ratio it's very
hard to work with that so let's turn it
into products okay so I'm going to
multiply through by C and C plus D so
multiply through by
sequence it so it's sort of like
possible to play right but you gotta be
careful cuz they're in for this it's not
hard to say because in the division now
see is both of these are positive sees
positive super see also must be positive
inequality stays the same right so what
we're gonna get is this that's fine so
now if I expand I have this okay now
look carefully at this line right
what's the parallel between this and
what I've got here well I've got my AC
my BD right yeah you can see it
I've got AC and BD here and then I've
got this BC on both sides okay so now
you can see will the fire if I don't
know that this is true I'm just
imagining if it were okay so let's go
back into color right I've established
this I've proved it okay so I'm going to
say for equation three
right it's ad it was my common theme be
seen
okay you see the difference in what I've
done it's kind of like this is the trick
that you might use for a trig identity
proof which is just like I can't see
what's going on here I have to add
something and subtract from both sides
but I can't see where he is
this is what you do to work out though
what you have to add it now I can
factorize and I'm really just rehearsing
the steps I just did but backwards yeah
okay now to get from here to what I'll
try to work with I'm gonna instead of
multiplying through see this is why it's
so you sort of put down your step
right I'll do my through so I'm gonna
end up with okay now I do need to
justify key why my inequality hasn't
changed direction just like here okay so
the reason I'll say is as C is greater
than zero and C plus 80 is also greater
than zero okay
sometimes in some proofs you might see
it written because like they might
divide through or multiply through by
lots and lots of different things they
might say as all factors are positive
okay because that's what they're really
doing they just noticing this supposedly
this is one of so many qualities there
okay good
now if you see this is the left-hand
side now I can do the same thing for the
right-hand side right I just want to go
the other way so I'm going to have to
add something different so that it
factorizes in a way which will give me
this side inequality and not that okay
so without doing this step right and
just Nessie right do you think you could
work out what do I need to add to both
sides of three we start with three again
what do I add to both sides now giggity
we wouldn't have B on C here right so it
was going to be our factor that's what
factored out okay so in order to have
that as a factor eventually I had to add
PC right
that was the contact of website now what
I want is a over D so therefore that
makes your teeth okay
instead of adding BC should add ad so
I'm gonna get okay just like before I
can factorize and then I'm gonna end up
with this fraction on this side okay so
now we draw all together yet but
you mean this pipe here yes absolutely
now the reason why I put it in there is
because it's the first thing you would
get right because normally I'm thinking
okay the the shortest path from here to
something related to this is this okay
but that's why that's why I've noticed
that it was insufficient okay and you
can see let's um let's name them so that
I can put them together I guess I'm up
to four and five right I will now say
from those two equations not any others
I don't try it call it inequalities I
don't need any others to show my
conclusion right I can say I'm now
changing it so its smallest to largest
okay so a couple lessons to learn right
number one be insanely careful about the
direction in equality okay the direction
of the inequality is everything and
secondly where there's one of these
kinds of tricks involved you want to add
something to both sides but what is it
okay think about what you're required to
prove but do it separately please do not
include that hand what you're actually
proving okay because as soon as you've
done this it's a big note okay and a lot
of people did similar kinds of things
with tree in the exam that just paused
you have to prove an identity will prove
that something was equal to some value
right if you assumed this is true and
then work with a your proof isn't
automatically invalid
tea results and that's basically it
Oh with any other kind of thing if if
your approach is to try to work out what
to do you simplify from both sides right
yeah yeah that's right if you if you are
if you are transferring anything over or
doing any operations to both side
lactase squaring which assume that is
true anything like that you know to
modification division addition
subtraction they're all fine so